The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So where were we last time?
So we had derived the
Fermion Lagrangian
which is at the
top of the board,
and really the only
difference between this
and what we talked about earlier
is that we had to perform
the multipole expansion.
So we distinguish between
collinear momenta that
are scaling like a collinear
momentum and momentum that
are scaling like an ultrasoft,
and only the collinear pieces
were showing up in here, and
same with the collinear gauge
field.
It was only showing up in here,
whereas both were showing up
in here.
There's only a single
type of derivative
here, because
ultrasoft and collinear
momenta are the same size
in the end component.
But they're different in
these other components,
so we had these labels
in this label operator
that picked out the
collinear momenta.
So we could define collinear
covariate derivatives,
if you like, with
this subscript n,
whereas this D is like a
full derivative that involves
both types of gauge field.
And then at the end of
lecture, it was kind of rushed,
but I was talking about the
collinear gluon Lagrangian,
and I said there is a
set of replacement rules
that we could make to
effectively do the same thing
that we did here.
And now I've just
written out for you
with that Lagrangian is with
those replacement rules.
So curly D is basically just
taking all the derivatives
and taking only the
leading order pieces.
So we take the collinear
pieces in this component
and this component.
We take the ultrasoft
pieces in this component.
And then if you wrote
the original Lagrangian
as a commutator of two
covariant derivatives,
you'd just replace it by
the leading order pieces,
and that's what the leading
order action will be.
Then, we had to think
about gauge fixing.
Since this is the
collinear gluon Lagrangian,
we should think about
collinear gauge fixing.
This here as a general
covariant gauge
fixing with parameter
tau, and then there's
a corresponding ghost term.
And in this Lagrangian, the
usual way it would look,
this would be i
partial, and then
I said that, because we don't
want the collinear gauge fixing
term to break ultrasoft
gauge invariance,
we're going to turn
that i partial into
a covariant derivative under--
we're going to include
this piece here
at the n dot a ultrasoft
to make it ultrasoft gauge
invariant at lowest order.
OK?
So that's really the only--
other than just doing this most
naive thing by just replacing
derivatives by
covariant derivatives,
and you might think,
well, I'll just keep
this as a partial derivative.
Since it's to
doing gauge fixing,
I don't need to
make it covariant,
but we do want to make it
covariant under the ultrasofts,
and that's why I write
this curly D ultrasoft.
OK.
So that gives you the
leading order Lagrangian.
Once you put together
this with what
you want for the
ultrasoft, then you
would have the full
leading order Lagrangian,
and the ultrasoft part
is actually very simple.
So for the ultrasoft
part, we just
take a full QCD action
for the ultrasoft field.
So this is just
q ultrasoft bar i
D slash ultrasoft q ultrasoft.
And likewise for the gluon
piece, it's just QCD,
and we would do the gauge
fixing without thinking
about any complications,
like these ones,
and these are just involving
ultrasoft fields, so just
QCD, just ultrasoft fields.
OK?
So the only place--
and you take everything
here together--
the only place that the
ultrasoft and collinear fields
talk to each other
in the Lagrangian
is in this single component n
dot partial, n dot a ultrasoft.
And that comes about basically
because of the power counting,
that this is really the only
place that these two things can
interact.
And we'll talk about the
implications of that later on,
but that's the leading
order Lagrangian.
So once you have this piece, and
this piece is pretty straight
forward with this
additional complication
of worrying about what
gauge symmetry means, which
we'll talk more about later.
But we had to be
careful not to break it,
when we introduced this
term, because we wanted
to in some sense have a gauge
fixing both for the collinear
gluon and a separate gauge
fixing for the ultrasoft gluon,
and that's why we
wanted to do this.
And then this piece
here is simple.
It's just QCD, because
it's, if you'd like,
it's the lowest
energy mode, and it
doesn't know about any
of the complications
that we had for the
collinear modes.
OK?
So any questions
about this so far?
OK.
So everything that we did
in deriving these actions
is tree level.
All the steps that we
did were tree level.
So you can ask, if
I start to do loops,
will there be some
Wilson coefficient
that shows up somewhere here?
Will I generate
some new operators
that I don't see here?
Those are reasonable
questions, and that's
what we're going
to address next.
So to go further,
we'll use symmetries,
and we're actually
going to consider
three different symmetries,
gauge symmetry, which I've
been promising you for a while,
reparameterization invariance,
and spin symmetry.
Where I'll put a question
mark by this last one,
because we need to answer the
question whether there even
is a spin symmetry.
These two here, this
number one and number two,
will turn out to
be quite important.
Number three is
not so important.
So reparameterization
invariance here
will be like reparameterization
invariance in HQET,
except now it's different.
We've introduced the
parameters and then n bar,
and we'll have to see
what kind of symmetries
we have with respect to
that choice of basis factors
that we made.
But it otherwise will be
analogous to our discussion
of HQET.
So let's actually first dispense
with the one that in some sense
is the least important,
this number three.
So first, let's revisit
our spinners a little bit.
So if I put together
the information
that we talked about
when we derived
the equation at the top of the
board there for the Lagrangian,
we worked out at a tree level
we have this formula that
relates the fields.
So from that formula, if we
just project onto the spinner
pieces, we can
write down a formula
that relates the spinners.
So throwing away
the gauge fields,
we have in momentum space
the u of p, the spinner,
would be related
to whatever spinner
we have for this cn field which
I call Un by that formula.
And then if you
take this formula,
you also see that if I
hit it with a projector,
n slash n bar slash over 4, if
I hit the u with a projector,
it's going to kill this piece.
Because the n slash n bar slash
can be pushed through the p
perp slash, then n
bar squared is 0,
so that kills that second piece.
So we also have this formula.
And then once you
have this formula,
you have the formulas
that we wanted for that.
OK?
But this actually,
this spinner here,
this Un is not exactly
the same as the spinner
that we talked about earlier.
So let me come back.
Let me come to that in a minute.
So first thing
you might consider
is whether, when I
take this cn field,
and I take the Lagrangian
up at the top of the board,
do I just get the collinear
propagator that we
talked about?
And indeed, you do.
It's kind of obvious for the
momentum-dependent parts,
and really you might only
worry about the spin.
And so if you
consider this formula,
and you consider the sum
over spins of u u bar which
is what's going to appear in
the numerator of the propagator
for the Fermion when you're
driving the Fermion propagator,
you get a sum over
the physical spins.
Then, from this formula, this
is a projector on something
you know how to do the spin sum
for which is the full theory
spinner.
And that spin sum
is p slash, so this
is like p slash sandwiched
between projectors.
And you could work out that
that's exactly the numerator
that we had before after a
little bit of Dirac algebra.
So that part works as expected.
If we take this
Lagrangian, and we work out
what the propagator is, we
get exactly the propagator
we got from expansion.
So quantizing lc0 gives
us that propagator.
But the situation is not quite
the same for the spinner.
And in some sense, this is not--
this point is not
absolutely crucial,
but actually, there's
a little simplification
I want to do in order to
discuss the spin symmetry,
and in order to do
that at this point,
it's important to
understand this point.
So that I'm going through
this in some sense,
because then it'll be very easy
to discuss what spin symmetry
we have in the theory.
So this guy is actually not
equal to our expanded spinner
which putting in
some normalization I
could write like this.
So this is what we
got by expanding,
something like this which is
very simple where this u is
equal to 1, 0 or 0, 1.
in the Dirac representation.
But that's actually
not what we get
if we just take the formula
up here and use this.
So let's see what we do get.
So if you use the
formula up there,
then you have the following.
So here's the full
theory spinner
with a conventional
normalization.
So this thing and this
thing here is the projector.
OK?
So you could work out what that
product is, and it turns out
that you can write it in
the following way which
is very closely related but
not precisely the same as what
we had before.
So you can write it in what
looks like the same form
as we have over here, except
this curly U, curly capital U,
is a more complicated object.
And it's just whatever I
get by multiplying these two
things out which turns
out to be something
I can write in that form.
So it's some
two-component spinner,
but it's got momentum
dependence, unlike our simple
1, 0 and 0,1.
But everything we said about
Un really depended only
on the fact that it could be
written in this form in terms
of some two-component spinner--
the fact that n
slash on it was 0,
the fact that it had
projection relation.
So these formulas here, if
you have a formula like these,
these formulas here are true.
OK?
So actually, it would be true
whatever spinner we have there.
So why should I want
this U twiddle spinner
and rather than the U spinner?
That actually has to do
with this reparameterization
invariant, so it'll become
clear when we talk about that.
But these extra terms
in U relative to those
for the other guy,
the simple U, actually
ensure the proper structure
under reparameterizations.
And basically, it'll
become clear in a moment,
but basically, if we wanted
to get this U spinner,
we should have a slightly
different projector,
which I'll call Pn prime.
So we could have used a
different projector which
is this one, and then
we could have come up
with another projector which
was the Pn bar projector which
would satisfy that the
sum is 1, if we wanted.
And this projector here, when
acting on the full theory
field, would have
given something
that would have
been proportional
to this combination over here.
OK?
So you just have to believe me.
I don't want to go
through the algebra,
or you can check it yourself.
But this projector here is not
invariant under that symmetry
of reparameterization variance.
When we talk about
RPI, it'll be clear
why we want a projector which
is this projector and not
the slightly different
projector which
has this extra n slash over 2.
OK.
But nevertheless,
the important point
that I wanted to
emphasize is really
that we have this
way of decomposing
the spinner, the true
spinner, for our field cn
in terms of a two-component
object, U twiddle.
OK?
So we are able to do that.
And if you want to talk about
spin symmetry of the theory,
it's easier if you use a
two-component notation.
So the reason that I
wanted to go through this
is really to have on
the board this equation,
which I can then use to
motivate writing down
to two-component version of cn.
And once I have a
two-component version of SCET,
then it's very easy to see
what the spin symmetry is.
So let's write down a
two-component version
of our collinear
quark Lagrangian.
You can do the same thing,
of course, in HQET right
down the two-component
version rather than
a four-component version.
If you have a
four-component version,
it has this projection relation.
If you have the
two-component version,
the projection
relation is built in.
The reason to consider
the four-component version
is if you want a
couple this object
to four-component fields,
like the ultrasoft field,
then it's, of
course, a nice thing
to have a
four-component version,
but some things are
easier in two components.
So take cn, and write
it as follows, where
this phi n has two components.
And I've set things up,
so the dimensions of cn
are equal to the
dimensions of phi n.
OK?
So I can take that formula, plug
it into our SCET Lagrangian,
and then I can, using the Dirac
representation for the gamma
matrices, write out a
Lagrangian for this phi n.
So that requires doing
a bit of algebra,
which I will take you through.
And then we get an
equivalent Lagrangian
but in terms of this field,
and it looks as follows.
OK.
So it's almost independent
of spin but not quite.
There's this sigma
3 sitting there.
If sigma 3 wasn't there,
it'd be like HQET,
where you have an SU2 symmetry.
The fact that sigma
3 is there means
you don't have an SU2 symmetry.
And really, all you
have is a U1 symmetry,
and that U1 really
corresponds just to helicity.
So in four-component notation,
that U1 would be the following.
It's projecting a spin operator
onto perpendicular indices
anti-symmetric in both of them,
and in the two components,
that just becomes a sigma 3.
So obviously, if we do
an exponential rotation
with respect to sigma 3,
sigma 3 commutes with sigma 3,
so does the identity.
And so we could have a
rotation of this guy by that,
and that's the
only spin symmetry
that you have is this helicity.
And so because of the
coordinates we're using,
this corresponds to the spin
along the direction of motion
which is the three
direction, if you like,
which sometimes we
denote by just saying
it's along the direction n which
is then more independent of how
we pick our axes.
So this symmetry
here is actually
related to what you would
call the chirality in QCD.
So it's not really
a new symmetry.
So this is just related
to the chiral rotation.
So if you look at gamma
5 times c and gamma 5
in our representation
would be 0, 1, 1 0.
And then if I write
it out in terms
of this two-component
thing, then that
is just giving me 1 over root 2,
and it's swapping up and down.
And so that just means that phi
n has gone to sigma 3 phi n.
So multiplying by gamma
5 is actually the same
as multiplying by sigma 3 in
the two-component notation.
OK?
So this is not really new
symmetry, and actually
all the usual things
that you would
say about chiral rotations
in QCD would apply here too.
So chiral rotations,
of course, are not
exact chiral rotations
are broken by masses.
Chiral rotations are broken
by non-perturbative effects.
You can worry about anomalies.
They are useful in perturbation
theory for quantifying
operators, and that
remains true here,
but if the collinear fields
were non-perturbative,
then you should worry about
those other things as well.
OK.
So spin symmetry, there's
not really anything new
there to talk about,
but along the way,
we saw we could write
SCET in two-component form
which is kind of nice.
So let's talk about something
that's more important which
is gauge symmetry.
Is there any questions about
the spin before we talk about
gauge symmetry?
AUDIENCE: So the extra term you
got in determining the theta n
bar, that is why you had the
minus n slash [INAUDIBLE]
and why you don't
have the full SU2?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I looked at it once,
but it's hard for me
to remember the answer.
I think not, but I think if
you do the other version,
then you just get something
more complicated here
but still breaks SU2.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is it--
I'm just looking
for [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: So they're
two disconnected fact.
The thing that I
wanted to motivate
that I could use this
formula, and I wanted
to be honest with you
about where that came from,
and that's why I told
you this other fact.
But I could have
jumped right here
and said, remember,
and glossed over it,
and that would have been
fine for this discussion.
So they're in some sense two
disconnected things, at least
in my mind.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have some intuition
for what theta n bar is?
PROFESSOR: For theta n bar?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Yeah.
It's really just saying--
my intuition for
it is really just
that, when you're producing
energetic particles,
it's what we did
at the beginning.
When you're producing
energetic particles,
these are the spin components
that you have at lowest order,
and that leads to, if you like--
the fact that you
have this form,
and you have this
projection relation
is kind of non-trivial,
even though you
don't have a spin symmetry.
There is something to it.
It's not like a SU2
symmetry of the spin,
but it does, for example,
when you go and look
at form factors, it does
lead to non-trivial relations
for those form factors.
So I don't call it a symmetry.
I don't think of
it as a symmetry,
because it's not a formal group
theory statement of Lagrangian,
but I think it's basically--
well, OK.
Let me not speculate
any further.
It caused some confusion in the
literature actually as well.
All right.
So what about gauge symmetry?
So we're doing a
non-abelian gauge theory.
A gauge transformation
is something like this.
And in order to just talk
about gauge symmetry, what
we need to do is we need to talk
about the gauge symmetries that
are related to the two type
of gluons that we have.
We have a collinear gluon.
We have an ultrasoft gluon.
You know that the field
acting like the connection
for that gauge symmetry.
So there should
be, in some sense,
a gauge symmetry associated
to the ultrasoft gluon
and a separate one associated
with collinear gluon,
if the meaning of these
things as gauge fields
is going to have
any sense to it.
So rather than have just this
set of gauge transformations
that we can make
in QCD, we should
have some more complicated
structure of gauge symmetry
in the effective
theory, because we
have a more complicated
structure of gauge fields.
So in order to talk
about U's, we're
going to want to
divide them into camps.
And the useful
thing to think about
is that you want to have
U's that, first of all,
leave you inside the
effective theory.
And really what this
means is that you
want talking about
gauge symmetry
to commute with your
discussion of talking
about power counting.
So by way of
example of this, say
you had a gauge
transformation that was large,
that made a formula like that
one, that i partial on it
was scaling like q.
OK?
So this would be a very
large momentum associated
to that spacetime dependence.
Then, if you talked about the
gauge transformation which
would be U times c, even if
this guy has collinear momentum
scaling, the new guy would
not because of this fact.
OK?
So if we want to talk
about gauge symmetries,
we want to talk about symmetries
that take us to the fields
that we've already decided to
have a certain power counting.
And we don't want the
gauge symmetry to mess
that up, so we're going to
demand that that's true.
So given that, we can think
about dividing up the gauge
symmetry into
pieces, into pieces
that have different
scaling in terms
of how big the
transformation are,
how the coordinates
are behaving.
And it's convenient
for this discussion
to divide them into three parts.
A global transformation,
where this guy is not
spacetime dependent, a
collinear transformation,
which I'll call Uc,
where i partial on Uc
scales like a
collinear momentum,
and then an ultrasoft U Us,
where the i partial scales like
an ultrasoft momentum.
And basically,
what we want to do
is we want to connect this gauge
transformation to the gauge
field for the collinears
and this transformation
to the gauge field
for the softs.
OK?
So one complication that
we have to deal with
is this momentum labels
that we were talking about.
Because the way
that we distinguish
between these types of momenta
and these types of momenta
was dividing things into
these labels and residuals.
Gauge transformations
are something
that's very nice in position
space but not so nice
in momentum space, and that's
because gauge transformations
are local transformations.
Local means local
in x not in P. So
what is simple multiplication
in position space
becomes convolutions
in momentum space.
So if you go over to this hybrid
notation that we developed,
then you would
have the following.
At this field, if I
do a transformation,
it goes into
something like that.
Where the way that you should
think of what this sum over q
is in the following way.
But if you have a
transformation in position space
that looks like that,
then in a momentum space,
that simple product
is convolution.
OK?
So this is one dimension, and
you'd have that correspondence.
And so this complication that
we have here just correspond
to the complication that
you'd have for any gauge
symmetry that you want to
write in momentum space.
But we can be slick about
this and introduce a notation
and then dispense with
it, because it's really
not a technical complication.
It's just a notational
complication.
So let's do that in
the following way.
Let's let Uc which is a
matrix with two indices
be defined by this
Uc of bl minus ql.
So I'll say define a matrix.
Then we can use a matrix
notation for the convolutions,
where we sum over
repeated indices,
and that takes care of this
notational complication.
So what is meant by this is that
the Pl, ql entry of this matrix
is a number, and that number
is given by this thing
that we call Uc Pl minus ql.
OK.
So then the formula
up here could just
be written in terms
of that matrix
as a kind of matrix
multiplication.
OK.
So what are the transformations
once we adopt that?
Let me write them down
and then talk about them.
So cn of x goes to Uc of x cn of
x, where you should understand
this thing is a matrix that
has two indices, like this,
also dependent on spacetime.
And I just dot over the repeated
indices in this thing which
is like a vector.
So this is like a matrix,
and this like a vector.
That makes it look like it's
the usual notation which
is the point of
introducing this notation.
So for the collinear
gauge field,
it's going to be
basically that it,
as we said over here,
that it becomes the gauge
field of that
transformation, and so that's
what this would be.
That would be the standard
gauge transformation,
and then there's one little
complication here, which is I
wrote curly D ultrasoft,
the ultrasoft derivative,
the thing that has the n
dot a ultrasoft field in it.
So the reason that
I wanted to do that
is because I'm thinking
here of the ultrasoft field.
When I'm thinking
about collinear fields,
I'm thinking of the ultrasoft
field as a background field.
And if I was to do a background
field gauge transformation,
then I would have a
covariant derivative
here under the background.
So this n dot a ultrasoft
is like a background field
to the collinear gauge field.
So this, if you want to make an
analogy of what this is like,
it's like the quantum gauge
transformation of a field that
has a background.
If you look up how
background field gauge
works and background
field transformations,
you'd have the same thing.
You'd have something covariant
under the background,
and that's what we're
going to do here as well.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Kind of
a silly question.
So UC of x is a matrix.
So what exactly UC
of p [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Well, no.
This is just a number.
So just think of this as
like this is some vector,
and this is some other vector.
The difference of these are
some label on this thing.
Right?
And for each value of this,
I get a different number,
and then for each
value it's based on,
I get a the different
number, but this thing
is just a number.
And I'm saying think of it
like a matrix in the sense of,
because we are thinking
of these as discrete--
AUDIENCE: But isn't
UC [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
That's another matrix.
It's an orthogonal matrix.
It's also a matrix
in that space.
Yeah.
So here, I'm defining a
matrix in a new space which
is this momentum space,
and that's just really
my way of making transformations
in momentum space look
like as simple as they
do in position space
by just having a matrix
notation for the convolutions.
AUDIENCE: So that number
is essentially a matrix.
PROFESSOR: It's a matrix,
yeah, in that space.
Good point.
What about the ultrasoft fields?
Well, ultrasoft fields shouldn't
transform under collinear gauge
transformations because
of exactly the same logic
that I gave you a minute
ago about why I shouldn't
be able to inject a hard
momentum like this one
into the effective theory.
If I want my ultrasoft
fields to remain ultrasoft,
then I can't let them
transform, because that would
spoil their power counting.
So q ultrasoft under
this Uc transformation
just goes to q ultrasoft,
and A ultrasoft
has to go to A ultrasoft.
So these things should not be
touched by that transformation.
AUDIENCE: So why cannot make
the ultrasoft and the collinear
talk to the--
PROFESSOR: Well,
we don't want that.
You could think of trying to
develop effective theory, where
they would mix.
Right?
But whenever you have
a Lagrangian that
mixes two fields, the
first thing you try to do
is to force them not to mix.
So it's better, say I set the
theory up so that they mixed.
The first thing I would try
to do to that Lagrangian
is make field
redefinitions to go
to some form of the
Lagrangian that wouldn't mix.
OK?
So I prefer, if you like,
to develop the one that
doesn't mix right
from the start,
and you could view it that way.
So you could always
think of I'm going
to tell you like two
sets of transformations.
You could always think of
formulating linear combinations
of those transformations.
Say these are the fundamental
ones, not the ones
you wrote down but
these other ones.
Right?
And then by some
manipulations, one
could go to the ones
I'm talking about.
All right.
So now, the other set of
transformations that we want
are these ultrasoft
ones, and for that type
of transformation, we don't
have the same type of problem
with the collinear.
We can't say the collinear
fields don't transform,
because that type
of transformation
doesn't spoil the collinear
field being collinear.
We can always add
ultrasoft momentum to it.
So these fields cn
and An will transform
like background fields--
sorry, like quantum
fields in a background.
So from the point of
view of the cn fields
which are the shorter
distance fields,
you can really
think of like what
we're doing here is
exactly like what
you would do if you had
quantum and background gauge
transformations.
And the physics of thinking
of the background as a longer
wavelength mode is
exactly the right way
of thinking about how
these fields which
are shorter wavelength think
about the ultrasoft fields.
So what that means is
that they transform
like matter fields in the
appropriate representation.
OK?
So with that in hand,
we can write down
how things transform
under the ultrasofts.
A Fermion just transforms
like that on the left,
and this, unlike our
notation over there,
this is one number for
all entries in the vector.
This guy doesn't
have any indices.
OK?
So this is like transforming
all the terms in the vector
by the same overall color
matrix, overall number
in the momentum matrix base.
So this guy should
transform like an adjoint,
and you can read the
adjoint as a U on each side.
So there's two ways of writing
the transformation here.
You could write it as like this.
If you wrote down an
adjoint transformation,
then this guy would have
two indices A and B,
and you'd have a
transformation like that,
where this is in the adjoint.
But if you want to write it
in terms of the U ultrasoft
that's e to the ita, which
is in the fundamental,
then you write it like this,
and those are equivalent.
So why are they equivalent?
So they're equivalent because--
well, OK.
Maybe I'll tell you later.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm always confused
about why n dot is a background
field to A ultrasoft,
because it actually
has the same size of
momentum, so its wavelength
is the same size.
PROFESSOR: The wavelength
is not the same size.
The component's power
counting is the same size,
but the n dot An field
carries momentum which have
P squared which is much larger.
AUDIENCE: Right.
P squared [INAUDIBLE]
wavelength, right?
PROFESSOR: So I'm talking
about the wavelength which
is related to that P squared.
So you think about the n dot An
field carries a large P minus
momentum still.
Right?
Even though it has a small--
it carries in order
a 1 P minus momentum.
So if it's confusing,
think about just the P
minus momentum.
The n dot An field, right,
has P minus, which is
the what are lambda to the 0.
So just let's think about
wavelength with respect
to P minus.
AUDIENCE: That's
definitely true, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Whereas the n dot A ultrasoft
field carries P minus, which
is what are lambda squared, so
just thinking about those two.
AUDIENCE: You were saying
conflating [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
All right.
We have room here to squeeze
the final transformation.
So the final transformations
are just what you'd expect,
that the ultrasoft fields
transform as regular gauge
fields.
So let me just squeeze that in.
All right.
So there's the regular
transformations
that you'd have
for a gauge field.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I just
want to clarify.
These two analogies
for background field
transformations, they're
not disconnected.
Right?
PROFESSOR: They're
not disconnected
in the sense-- that's right.
Yeah.
So if you take the
background field notation,
and you just really
think about that,
then this is how you would
transform the quantum
field into the background
gauge transformation.
And this is how you would
transform the quantum field
under the quantum
gauge transformation.
Yeah.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: So even if you made
these to separate the gauge
transformation for
just [INAUDIBLE]
they still have the
same quantum numbers?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: Are they going
to meet at some level?
PROFESSOR: We're going
to make sure they don't.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
In some sense, we really
want-- the picture is this one
that we had earlier,
where we really
want the collinear
fields to live up here,
so we had these hyperbolas.
Right?
We want this guy to live
up here and this guy
to live down there
in momentum space.
So this was P minus.
This is P plus.
So we want them to live
in different places.
They have the same
quantum numbers,
except we want them
in momentum space
to live in different
places and to describe
different degrees of freedom.
Right?
So everything that we did
here is exactly related
to this picture, that we
want to talk about this guy
as having larger momentum, talk
about gauge transformations
that shuffle things
around with components
that have large momentum
versus small momentum.
All right.
So we're going to
hypothesize that these gauge
transformations are the
fundamental symmetry
of the effective theory.
And I tried to motivate
them physically
by this analogy with
background field gauge
and thinking about a longer
wavelength mode with respect
to a shorter wavelength mode
which is in this picture
exactly the fact that
this hyperbola is
higher than this one.
Maybe the hyperbola
should stay on the board.
OK?
So they multipole, where
the multipole expansion
that we did between these
fields and the statement
that this is a longer
wavelength mode
is exactly the fact that
there's a separation
between these guys.
So we'll take these to be the
fundamental transformations
that do not get corrected
by power corrections.
And I'm not claiming
that that's necessarily
a unique way of getting
to the effective theory.
You could think
of there might be
an example in the literature
of where people were thinking
of other gauge transformations.
These are the ones that
people talk about now,
but in the early
days, I think, there
is an example in the
literature, where
people are thinking of
other transformations,
and you could prove
that they could
be connected to these ones.
But we'll just
take the ones that
are the most useful
from the start
and not worry too much about
what we could have done.
All right.
So there's no mixing
in the power counting,
and that's something
that we like.
Set up that way.
If there was a mixing,
if we connected things
that were different
sizes in lambda,
then you could say, well,
that the power counting,
that the gauge transformation
induces power suppressed terms.
And you could end up
with some situation
where you're trying to connect
things at different orders,
and we don't have that here.
And that's because,
if we want to think
about this thing as a
symmetry, it should really
be a symmetry of the
leading order action
that shouldn't require some
other sub-leading terms
necessarily to compensate
for it, at least
for a gauge symmetry like this.
We'd like to think that what
the meaning of gauge symmetry is
and the redundancy
encoded in gauge symmetry
is all something
that you're talking
about at the order of
the leading order action.
And you're not talking
about redundancies
in fields in sub-leading
order, et cetera.
OK.
So let's do an
example, now that we
have this, of how it comes in.
And I want to come
back to our example
of our heavy-to-light current
and talk about gauge symmetry
there.
If you just took the
tree level result
that we had in
that case, then we
had something that just
involved these two guys,
and this hv field was ultrasoft.
This guy was collinear.
So if you did a
Uc transformation,
then under our rules, what you'd
find is that the cn transforms,
and this guy doesn't,
the h doesn't.
So that would not
be gauge invariant.
But actually, we saw that this
also wasn't the lowest order
current.
There was this additional thing,
the Wilson line showed up,
and that Wilson line is
going to fix this issue.
It's going to make
it gauge invariant.
So we have to ask, how
do Wilson lines transform
under gauge symmetries?
And that Wilson line
in position space,
I called it something like this.
I can't remember if I
used a twiddle or a bar.
We'll use a bar here for the
position space Wilson line.
So in general, in just
a regular gauge theory,
the Wilson line
between two points
transforms at the endpoints.
So you get U of x.
Then, you get a U dagger of y.
So if you like,
what we would say
for this Wilson line is that
we have a U of x on one side
and a U dagger of minus
infinity on the other side.
Minus infinity is really
long wavelength physics,
and so we have to
worry a little bit
about the overlap between
our different types of gauge
transformations.
I divided them into three
camps-- collinear, ultrasoft,
and the global, so let
me do the following.
To avoid some double counting
with what I called U global,
let's just simply take,
since U global acts the same
everywhere, let's just simply
take Uc dagger at minus
infinity to be 1.
So this is at some
particular spacetime point.
We take it to be 1,
and this U global
will transform at that point.
We then know there's no overlap
between Uc and U global.
OK?
Then, that's enough
to ensure that.
So with that, our guy under a
collinear gauge transformation
just transforms on one side.
If you like, what's happening
is that the coordinate here
corresponds to this
very large momentum,
and we're stretching
ourselves out to long distance
physics which is corresponding
to the smaller momentum.
So when I think
about transformations
that should be collinear, I want
them to be associated to the x.
And I want to associate other
types of transformations
to what's going on at
infinity which is really
a spacetime of its own, which is
this ultrasoft spacetime that's
sitting at the
collinear infinity.
So that's why I want,
actually, it to look like this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] just
with the collinear fields?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So this guy here is a
path-ordered exponential,
and it just involved
the n bar guy.
Yeah.
So that's what it was
in position space,
and in momentum space,
they called it W,
and it was a sum over
a bunch of things.
I'm not going to--
we had this formula.
Let me not write
it all out again.
As a short form
for that formula,
we can write the
following formula
which is given our
notation that we've
developed a useful way
of thinking about it.
So if we formally expand
out this exponential,
and we just keep the order of
that expansion, where the P
bar acts on all the fields to
the right, that will correctly
reproduce this denominator,
the sum over permutations
is something that
we still have to do.
It was 1 over n factorial,
k factorial in here.
M factorial with this notation.
OK?
But this is like
a little shorthand
for that messy formula.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think it's related
to the gauge transformation
equation before.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you get
the i epsilon prescription?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So that actually
is related to the fact that,
when you look at the--
for this Wilson line
with the i epsilon,
it's not related to the gauge
transformation at infinity,
but it's related to the fact
that the path goes that way.
So that when you do
the Fourier integral,
the fact that it goes from minus
infinity to x will give the i0.
OK?
But for these Wilson
lines here, if you
think about what's
happening at the place
where the i0 would
actually matter,
that's exactly the 0 bin.
So it's going to
be a little more--
Yeah.
So you don't really care.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I can only say that--
we'll explain what I
just said to Ilia more
when we come to it later on.
OK.
So this field here has--
I said, it's a momentum
space, but then I wrote x.
So really what I mean
by momentum space
is momentum is in the
label momentum space.
There's some guy, and the labels
are these labels on the fields
here.
Right?
So there's still an x,
and that x corresponds
to the residual coordinate
that we were using
to do the multipole expansion.
So in some sense, this isn't
simply the Fourier transform
of that, because of that.
It's still knows
about the separation
between the large momentum
and the soft momentum
from that multipole expansion.
So this dependence
on x allows us
to think about the multipole
expansion on these Wilson
lines.
It encodes all the
residual momenta,
and the fields in the Wilson
line carry a residual momenta.
So we're just putting
our notation to use here.
And if you really strictly
want to connect to that formula
up there, then you would take
the residual momenta to be 0.
And then the Fourier
transform with respect
to just the large
momentum Pl minus
gives a line which
is just depending
on that one single coordinate.
So if we just had
a coordinate which
is conjugate to the
large momenta, which
is the thing that's
showing up here
are the large momenta, then
that would be the analog of what
we were talking about up here.
Where in general,
this thing also
has a dependence on
the residual x, which
we'll make use of in a minute.
OK.
So let's think
about, so I told you
how this Wilson line
transforms under Uc see.
How does it transform
under U ultrasoft?
So under Uc, again using
this matrix-type notation,
it's just Uc.
So this is a matrix
multiplication
in momentum space.
What about under an
ultrasoft transformation?
Well, under an ultrasoft
transformation,
this should be a derived--
in some sense, under a
collinear transformation,
it was a derived
quantity, because we knew
of the gauge field transform.
The thing that gave us the
transformation of the Wilson
line is just the transformation
of the gauge field.
OK?
So that's what led to,
actually, this form, once we
put in this fact.
So under the ultrasoft
transformation,
we just take the transformation
that we have for the collinear
gauge field, and
then we derive how
the Wilson line should transform
under the ultrasoft gauge
symmetry.
OK?
So how does this guy transform?
This guy transforms by
putting U's on the left
and the right that are at x.
But every field in
this exponential
has the same, U U
dagger, multiply it,
think about expanding that out.
All the U U daggers that are
next to each other cancel.
You just get an overall U
U dagger that comes right
outside the exponential.
So this guy is just transforming
with U ultrasoft of x.
Wilson line back again,
U ultrasoft dagger of x,
and that's because this
Wilson line with our notation
is really a local thing with
respect to the coordinate x.
All the fields sit at x.
OK?
So it just transforms
like that, because that's
how the gauge field
inside it transforms.
So in some sense,
both of these are
derived from the
transformation of An,
but it's easier to think about
how a Wilson line transforms
and then think about
how it should transform
under collinear than just
go through the An route
and impose this condition.
OK.
So let's come back now to our
full current which was this,
that had the Wilson line in it.
And now if you ask how
it transforms under Uc,
you see what's going to happen.
You get Uc dagger, Uc,
and the ultrasoft guy
doesn't transform,
and then these cancel.
So it's invariant under
the transformations
that have momenta of
order of the ultrasoft.
It'll have a momentum of
what are the linear scale.
There's two objects in this
thing that have momenta
that can be of that size.
The gluons, they're in W in
this collinear quark field.
Both of those things transform,
but that transformation
cancels between the two things.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Whoops,
that's important.
Thank you.
And then under an
ultrasoft transformation,
we can also transform this
guy, and then everybody's
transforming.
Gamma, of course, has
not got color indices,
and again, it's gauge invariant.
OK?
Missed a gamma.
Gamma's not so important.
All right?
So this current that
we derived earlier
is actually invariant under two
different types of symmetries
which are really momentum space
splitting of a standard gauge
symmetry into pieces where we
have a large momenta and pieces
where you have these
larger momenta, collinear
momenta and pieces where
we have a smaller momenta,
this ultrasoft momenta.
But both of these
types of momenta
are momenta that we're allowing
inside the effective theory.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just
trying to remember
that the ultrasoft scale was
the same for the [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The momentum of the ultrasoft--
the ultrasoft momentum
of the collinear
quark, you pulled
out mv, and then
the remaining part was
ultrasoft in the discussion
for this particular thing.
All right.
So it's the Wilson
line, the moral of this
is that what we were doing
before, where we're integrating
out those collinear
gluons, is actually
connected to gauge symmetry.
Because without
that Wilson line,
we wouldn't have a result
that's invariant under the type
of gauge symmetry we've
been talking about.
So this Wilson line carries
these n collinear gluons,
and those gluons would be the
gluons that in the full theory
would give you a gauge symmetric
result. They would combine.
They would be the attachments
to the heavy quark that
combined with attachments
to the light quark
to give you a result
that's invariant,
if you looked at word
identities, for example.
But in the effective
theory, these are just
put into a Wilson line, because
that's the leading order
way that they can
show up, but still we
have a gauge invariant answer.
So the Wilson line is really
needed for the gauge symmetry.
And finally, the ultrasofts, as
can be clear from the notation,
the ultrasofts can
just as well include
the global transformation,
if you like.
So we don't really need three.
We could put the global
back with the ultrasofts.
Then, we just have two.
All right.
So that's our symmetry.
That's an example
of how it works.
Now, let's talk about
covariant derivatives.
So gauge symmetry ties
together regular derivatives
with the gauge field, and
here, what it ties together
at the following things.
So because of the treatment
of the A ultrasoft
field as a background,
it actually ties together
both of these things.
And then it does what you
expect in a collinear sector.
It ties together the derivative
with the gauge field.
And if you're acting
on ultrasoft fields,
then there's an ultrasoft
covariant derivative
which is just like that.
So now, you can ask
the question if I just
had this gauge
symmetry, which is going
to force me to use covariant
derivatives-- which I was
already thinking ahead
to when I wrote down
the Lagrangian earlier.
Right?
We already wrote it in terms
of these kind of objects,
so it seems like
we're good to go.
So you can ask the
question if I just
have power counting,
the cn that we
decided we're going to use, and
gauge symmetry, is that enough?
Am I done?
Do I have everything I need for
the leading order Lagrangian?
So power counting told us that
we had this type of derivative,
and that we could have two
of these perp derivatives.
OK?
So those are the two type
of terms we were getting.
There's no other order lambda
squared field structures that
would have the right dimensions
and that could do the job.
So these are really the only
two that we have to think about.
So you could try to
think about maybe
I can have something with some
additional n bars floating
around, but really,
it boils down--
since you need to
get a lambda squared,
you need either two
perp derivatives.
You need two of them, because
you still have a rotation
symmetry around the
direction of motion,
or you could have an n dot D.
But there is one operator
that is not rolled out,
by gauge symmetry alone,
and that is this operator.
When we wrote the operator, we
had D perp slash D perp slash.
But nothing stops me from doing
something similar in some way
by just taking the D perps and
contracting them, like that.
That's a different operator
than the D perp slash D perp
operator that we got before.
Oops, only one of those.
OK?
So this operator is
a different operator.
In a priori, you
could say, well,
do loop connections
generate this operator which
is different than the D perp
slash D perp slash operator.
The answer is no, actually,
but so far what we've done,
it's not enough to see that.
So we need actually this other
symmetry that I alluded to,
the reparameterization
invariance,
and that will actually
rule out this guy.
So what's RPI?
Well, when we
formulated this theory,
we needed a direction
for the collinear line
or for the collinear particles.
And then we needed an
auxiliary vector n bar,
and we formulated
the whole set up
in terms of this n and n bar.
But having vectors like
that that we write down,
that breaks Lorentz invariance
in the same way that
specifying v mu in HQET
breaks Lorentz invariance.
So if you say that m mu
nu is the set of Lorentz
transformations, the
usual six generators that
are anti-symmetric, then
the ones that are broken
are these ones.
And there's five of them,
and the one that's not broken
is this one which corresponds
to rotations about the three,
axis with the axis
specified by n.
OK?
So those rotations would act
in the components of these guys
that are 0, if you like.
So there's no issue
there, and these guys
are the guys that are
connected to the pieces that
were non-0 in general.
So there's going to be a
larger, because there's
five things here and
because there's two vectors,
it's going to be a larger set
of reparameterization symmetries
than in HQET.
First, talk about just the
n and n bar themselves.
There's three types of
reparameterization invariance
that would leave
n squared equals 0
and bar squared equals 0
and n dot n bar equals 2.
And those were the formulas
that we were using over and over
again really.
Everything else was
just convention.
OK?
So what are those three types?
Well, we could take
n, and we could
change it by some amount
in the perp direction
and leave n bar unchanged.
And since n bar dot
something perp is 0,
that would satisfy this, or
we could do the opposite.
That would be type two.
So don't change n,
and change n bar.
And so this is two
transformations
there's two things specified
by this perp guy and two here.
And then there's one more
which is called three,
and this one let me
write it like this.
It's a simultaneous
transformation
of these two guys, where I just
do a multiplicative factor.
Well, a multiplicative
factor is not
going to change the fact that's
the square of something 0.
The place where the
normalization comes in
is this n dot n bar, and
if I just rescale them
both by an opposite amount, then
that remains satisfied as well.
So I formulated this in
terms of an infinite--
I'm going to think about this is
an infinitesimal transformation
for delta perp, infinitesimal
for epsilon perp.
I could also expand
this exponential
and think of it
as infinitesimal,
but the finite one's easier.
So let's just think of
the finite transformation
in the last one.
Now, this is an
effective theory.
So whenever we think
about transformations,
we should think
about power counting.
We just spent a lot
of time thinking
about that for gauge
symmetry, and we should think
about power counting here too.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So what I was just about to talk
about, how big things can be.
So the power counting that's
the right power counting
for these guys, so these things
are infinitesimal or finite,
but they also have some counting
in a different space which
is the power counting space.
And the right power counting
for these guys is as follows.
So this means I can
make arbitrarily
large transformations in a
power counting sense of type
two and type three.
There's no constraint.
That's what this means, so that
maybe that's easier to swallow.
This one, there is a
constraint, and the reason
that you can think of
there being a constraint,
I can give you a simple
example, and then you'll
see how you would derive
the other things as well.
So think of n dot
P. If you transform
n dot P, that becomes n dot--
think of this is n mu, P mu.
That becomes n mu, P mu
plus delta perp dot P perp.
So this is order lambda
squared, so this better
be order lambda squared.
But this momentum
here is order lambda,
so you need to have a power
counting for the delta perp
that makes it of order lambda.
In order to keep the transform
guy the same size as the guy
you started with,
because I don't
want to consider transformations
that would take me away
from my power counting,
that would violate it.
So imposing that this thing
is of order lambda squared
says that this is true.
If you go through the same
logic for the other guys,
the n bar component
was order lambda 0,
so you can make the epsilon
perp of order lambda 0.
It doesn't cost you anything,
because there's no constraint.
You're not making something
that would mess up
the power counting.
All right.
So what does this
correspond to physically?
So type three is
actually pretty simple.
Type three is like a
boost along-- if you
think about our
back-to-back vectors,
type three is like
the analog of a boost,
but you're transforming
it in the passive sense
of transforming the axis.
And what the outcome
is is very simple.
It just implies that any
operator that has an n
must have a corresponding
n bar sitting next
to it, effectively.
So I'll give you some examples.
So really, if you have--
let's just say it this way--
if you have an n bar mu
in the numerator, then you
either have a corresponding n
in the numerator, or--
well, you have an n
bar in the denominator.
Since we could have n bars
in the denominator and that
was showing up in some places.
Those are the two possible
ways of compensating
for the transformation.
So it's just like a simple
counting that you have.
So if you look at our lc
0, we had various terms.
One of them was n bar slash
1 over i n bar over D.
So here, we have an n
bar in both the numerator
and the denominator,
and that compensates
for the transformation.
And then in another term, we
had an n bar slash n dot D,
and then that again is invariant
in this type of transformation.
What about type one and two?
So type one is the following.
So think about these guys
as in this kind of language
they would be back to back.
We're trying to
describe the physics
in this cone for the
collinear particles,
and n was the vector that was
pointing inside that cone.
What this is saying, type one,
is that I can rotate that guy,
and as long as I'm not
rotating it by too much--
i.e.
I'm rotating it
by a small amount
of order lambda,
which you can think
of as staying inside the cone--
then I can describe
everything equally well
by some other vector
that lives in that cone,
and I can decompose the
momenta and the modes
in terms of that vector, and
it will work equally well.
OK.
So that's what type one
is physically doing,
and so you're not making a
large transformation here,
because you want to
still be inside the cone.
You still want something that's
pointing in the collinear
direction.
Type two is related to
the fact that this n bar
vector was just an
auxiliary vector that we
used to decompose things.
We didn't really care about it.
It didn't have a strong
physical motivation.
It was just needed because we're
using light cone coordinates.
So I can make a very large
transformation of that guy.
So here's a large
transformation,
and I can use some other guy.
And we gave you an example
earlier, which was 3,
2, 2, 1 as a possible
value for the n bar,
and that's something
that you could think
of getting to by a finite
type two reparameterization
transformation.
OK?
So that's the picture for what
these transformations are,
and we will finish up
talking about them next time
and will show that actually this
additional term that we could
write down in the
Lagrangian is actually
ruled out reparameterization
symmetries.